hamza est un activiste de la première
heure membre d'une association
tunisienne pour la justice et l'égalité
il a fait les frais des violences
policières lors des dernières
manifestations alors qu'ils défilaient
pour plus de justice sociale et moins de
répression
après 72 heures de garde à vue musclée
sans manger ni boire
il nous raconte son cauchemar et gégé le
18 janvier dernier je suis descendu pour
manifester contre les violences
policières et j'ai été arrêté et emmené
au commissariat de bab souika
il m'a emmené par la suite à la caserne
de bouchoucha là où j'ai eu le droit à
un traitement inhumain
ils ne m'ont pas laissé voir un docteur
ils ne m'ont pas permis de manger de
boire suffisamment ils m'ont laissé
dormir à même le sol sans couverture ce
sont des exemples de pratiques ont
dénoncé plusieurs associations notamment
amnesty international et front line
defenders est si hamza a pu être libéré
rapidement son réel traumatisme physique
ou psychologique
d'autres notamment certains de ses amis
n'ont pas eu cette chance
je me souviens qu'au commissariat de bab
souika un jeune a été dévêtue par la
police humiliés et agressées
sexuellement
ils ont menacé de le violer s'ils ne
dénonçaient pas les jeunes de son
quartier qui ont participé aux violences
nocturnes des quartiers populaires un
autre jeune de la banlieue de tunis dans
la même cellule que - a été violemment
frappé par la police
si son état a nécessité une
hospitalisation d'urgence malgré ses
douleurs et son état la police ne
voulais pas le transférer à l'hôpital
il a fallu l'intervention de
l'organisation contre la torture pour
qu'ils puissent être évacués
ces dernières semaines de vives tensions
ont éclaté entre manifestants et forces
de l'ordre dans plusieurs villes du pays
bombe lacrymogène coups de matraque ou
encore arrestations des méthodes
musclées qui ont provoqué la mort d'un
jeune homme de 22 ans
le gouvernement a indiqué de son côté
que les forces de l'ordre ont agi de
façon professionnelle dans un contexte
tendu causée par la crise économique et
sociale violence injustifiée
arrestations arbitraires tortures
psychologiques et parfois physiques des
récits se multiplient sur le bureau des
défenseurs des droits de l'homme et des
avocats tunisiens ces récits sont
devenus le quotidien dans mon dernier
pour lui le contexte politique actuel
est une application des réformes
notamment celles concernant la police
tendent à maintenir le pays dans l'ombre
de l'ère ben ali
pendant cette crise politique la police
est pas tout partout l'appareil mais il
y a des des cercles dans la police qui
profite de cette crise politique pour
essayer de réduire faire revivre les
mauvaises traditions de la répression de
la violence policière da preuve c'est
que donc à peu près 80 % des détenus ont
été libérés par les tribunaux donc ce
qui montre que les arrestations commises
par la police n'était pas dans les
règles de l'art il n'était pas légal on
essaie d'assister les victimes
légalement psychologiquement socialement
en lutte contre l'impunité à travers un
système d' aide légale de dépôt de
plainte
dans ce contexte le gouvernement s'est
doté d'une instance qui vise à lutter
contre ces pratiques illégales
faty jaraï en est le garant depuis des
années il travaille en étroite
collaboration avec des organisations
internationales des fondations
étrangères et des associations locales
pour débarrasser le pays de ses vielles
pratiques liberticides et illégale selon
lui tortures et violences policières ne
concerne pas une politique d'état mais
sont les restes de mauvaises pratiques
individuelles issues de 23 ans de
pouvoir de l'ancien président tunisien
malheureusement la tenture existe
toujours en tunisie et contrairement à
il ya dix ans ce n'est plus une
politique et à l'est c'est l'une des
conséquences sur la révolution de 2011
malheureusement on constate encore une
certaine forme d'impunité de la part de
certains policiers qui n'appliquent pas
la loi et ne semble pas avoir évolué
depuis dix ans ces pratiques déviantes
sont le coeur même de notre travail et
nous devons tous travailler dans ce sens
notamment en proposant des formations
forces de l'ordre afin qu'ils puissent
devenir de vrais agents qui respecte
l'institution et les droits et les
libertés des uns devant lui et notamment
le respect des procédures d'arrestation
dix ans après la révolution la tunisie
semble toujours habité par ses vieux
démons dans un contexte de crise
politique qui gangrène tout un état le
combat des associations et des
organisations internationales semblent
plus que jamais indispensable pour
libérer la tunisie de certaines
pratiques qui semblent avoir marqué
toute une génération